bonjour je suis tel c'est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du
soulier
[Musique]
dans histoire de souliers nous allons
explorer l'univers de la chaussure
féminine de l'escarpin à la ballerine en
passant par la chaussure compenser les
bottines les bottes les mary jane
les cuissardes et toutes les autres
mais comme les et bette midler donné une
fille des chaussures correct et elle
peut conquérir le monde
dans histoire de souligner je vous dirai
tout sur cette arme de destruction et de
séduction massive les femmes et leurs
chaussures où la relation la plus
fusionnel qui soit avec un accessoire
votre vie ne sera joué car la quête du
graal trouver la chaussure parfait en
somme ou sur son histoire et les
infinies possibilités offertes à nos
gens aujourd'hui dans histoire de
souligner la sandale d'où vient-elle
comment la portée des professionnels de
la mode et de la confection de
chaussures pour vous expliqueront son
histoire saviez vous par exemple que des
l'egypte ancienne les sandales était
déjà différenciée selon le pied gauche
et le pied droit
vous découvrirez ensuite quelles sont
les tendances du moment
nos professionnels vous aiguilleront
avec leurs conseils shopping
ils vous apprendront également ceux qui
écoutent hérité en tout prix enfin nous
vous présenterons des modèles de
sandales complètement extravagant que
vous n'avez probablement jamais vu et
qui ont fait fureur dans des milieux de
la haute couture et du design mais tout
d'abord allant voir ce que vous en
pensez vous
[Musique]
paris c'est au coeur de la capitale de
la mode que nous sommes allés enquêter
pour savoir ce que vous pensiez de leurs
sandales
alors mesdames votre avis énormément de
sandales non moi je pars compression
asim les jambes
enfin il a un peu plus les chaussures
ouvertes l'été ou dans les soirées un
peu plus classe mais on peut se mettre
des chaussures
moi je sais que ça fait
trèfles éminente les
[Musique]
un petit trait fin en général et à ses
places et
ce soir qui m'inspire elle est tout
simplement indispensable en été et les
créateurs ne manque pas de fantaisie
pour nous faire des pieds sexy mais
saviez vous qu avant d'être cet
accessoire décontractée la sandale été
riche de symboles
découvrons ensemble l'histoire d'une des
plus anciennes chaussures au monde qui a
connu des matériaux très surprenant
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la sandale vous évoque la
sandale et c'est l'été c'est la plage
c'est la mer c'est vraiment un modèle
hyper aéré avec des cuirs qui sont très
fins qui sont très doux très souple par
exemple en date ce que tu veux merci
voilà des couleurs très estival dure aux
puces ya des couleurs un peu fluo des
couleurs pastel de la paillette
voilà moi ça m'évoque une jolie jambes
bronzées une petite robe blanche et des
chaussures un peu p tit donc la féminité
et la légèreté estivale la légèreté
surtout la sandale est-elle encore à la
mode
oui la sandale et indémodables comme
l'escarpin après il ya énormément de
modèles de sandales
là on est en train d'en développer de
nouveaux et notamment une sandales
gladiateur qu'on s'imagine en plate
forme avec la toile de jouy du tissu du
satin des couleurs hyper vivre voilà
donc les modèles évoluent mais la
sandale restera toujours dans nos
dressings et je pense pour encore
quelques années
[Musique]
la tendance la dernière tendance des
sandales sait déjà
encore une fois avec beaucoup de
couleurs mais aussi avec des pierres et
des bijoux on peut faire des sandales
plates des sandales à talons des
spartiates à talons c'est à dire qu'il
faut pas la porter obligatoirement en
short avec on peut l'accessoiriser avec
un jean une robe une jupe en s'habillant
un peu plus couverts qu'en étant en
vacances
voilà et on peut toujours porter une
jolies sandales celle qui m'a marqué et
que j'aime beaucoup c'est la tribu de
yves saint laurent cette sandale est
vraiment très féminine très jolie et
très confortable
[Musique]
l'origine de la sandale est apparu dès
l'egypte ancienne
elle avait pour vocation de protéger le
pied de la chaleur du sol et de pouvoir
évacuer le sable facilement avec ses
ouvertures les égyptiens distinguait
déjà le pied gauche du pied droit
la sandale était alors confectionné en
cuir alliés ou pas écrit ces mêmes en
papyrus et c'est un vrai symbole social
seuls les hommes libres pouvaient porter
des chaussures les esclaves n'y étaient
pas autorisés puis des grecs
empruntèrent cette sandale égyptienne et
nourrir les lanières sur le coup de pied
c'est la plus ancienne chaussure que
l'on ait pu retrouver
[Musique]
pendant des siècles cette chaussure n'a
pas évolué et n'était constitué que
d'une simple semelle et de deux lanières
il faut attendre le moyen-âge pour que
la sonde elle devienne un objet de mode
les sandales porté par les femmes
s'améliore alors avec des matières
telles que le satin le velours tandis
que les sandales portée par les hommes
reste dans des matières brutes mais
pragmatique cuir daim ou croûte de porc
[Musique]
c'est dans les années 1920 que la
spartiate revient au goût du jour un
fameux cordonnier du nom de randy ni
réinvente un la spartiate dans le petit
village de pêcheurs qui étaient alors
saint tropez la maison qu'est cliquant
également tropézienne se lance à son
tour dans la création de cette fameuse
partiel depuis lors ces sandales sont
toujours fabriqués à la main par ces
deux maisons et ont été portées par les
plus grandes stars
[Musique]
parlons également du cas de la tong qui
avait pris son nom définitif lors de la
guerre du vietnam et qui signifie
lanières encore une fois ce type de
sandales à lanières autour du gros
orteil s'est directement inspiré du
modèle égyptien
elles ont d'ailleurs envahi le brésil
avant d'envahir la france dans les
années 1970 mais les sandales ne sont
pas forcément des chaussures plates
elles peuvent même revêtir une allure
vertigineuse
[Musique]
pour être tendance cet été on peut être
un peu tendance de l'été dernier donc le
scandale est une produit qui bougent peu
et dans le sauna l'on travaille toujours
des livres qui proviennent de graisse et
d'égypte donc c'est des choses qui ont
des brides et je pense que cet été pour
être très belle on peuvent se permettre
d cuir métallisé le sandale qui le sont
elles qui m'a inspiré le plus c'était
une modèle de givenchy il y a neuf ans
et c'était la première fois que j'ai vu
une ce parti est revisité par la haute
couture avec des creux des zones m
diffusé dans le sondage donc ce que j'ai
apprécié dans sept modèles c'était qu'il
y avait un talent de 7 cm donc une très
grande hauteur et il y avait une côte et
violente et combatif danse est spartiate
qui m'interpellait alors le journalise
idéal bizarrement c'est un final comme
ça et j'explique pourquoi parce que ça
en boîte la cheville de la fis donc la
chaussure va toujours être sur son pied
et il y a une cote est un tout petit peu
couvrante mais pas trop de son pied en
avant donc dans une modèle comme ça
comme quelqu'un qui se préoccupent d'une
fille c'est non seulement esthétique une
fois portée mais elle serait très très
bien chaussés
la sandale vous évoque la sandale et
et toujours un produit pour moi est à la
fois très féminin sexy et puis en même
temps il peut avoir un côté beaucoup
plus working girl et chaussures de tous
les jours tout dépend comment on la
porte
tout dépend la couleur tout dépend de la
matière disons que ces choses-là fait
que la même personne se porter une
sandale de ses couleurs la très flashy
et la porte est la même
enfin la même chose en noir ce sera deux
loups qui seront radicalement différent
donc aujourd'hui la sandale c'est
vraiment enfin c'est intemporel
évidemment c'est vraiment des styles de
chaussures qui reviennent chaque saison
on décide de l'avoir compensées ou pas
ça peut être plat tout dépend ensuite
d'une chose pour moi qui est extrêmement
important c'est la bride cheville alors
la bride à l'âge fini soit elle est
simple comme celle ci mais si on décide
d'avoir quelque chose d'un petit peu
plus compliqué d'avoir quelque chose
vraiment qui fait le tour de la cheville
ça les rend tout de suite beaucoup plus
habillée et voilà c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très très très très féminin je
trouve là la sandale
tout est dans la bride et la hauteur de
talon donc moi la sandale c'est un
modèle que je trouve
indispensable dans une garde-robe et
puis chaque saison 10 ans qui a toujours
des nouvelles choses bon ça pousse les
femmes à sans cesse de voir toucher au
porte-monnaie puisque on essaye de nos
créateurs à chaque fois de sortir des
nouvelles choses soient des nouvelles
matières les nouvelles couleurs d'une
nouvelle forme
mais voilà la sandale c'est on arrive
c'est pas comme une ballerine dont on
n'arrive pas un petit peu plus
renouveler parce que bach ya plus à
faire la chandelle à la fois quand je
vous disais yalla yalla hauteur de talon
il ya le patin et il ya sept bris de là
donc on peut jouer suivant les saisons
sur ces différents sur ces différentes
choses qu'elle soit ouverte ou bien
parfois qu'elles soient un peu plus un
peu plus ferme et donc on peut quand
même gagner pas mal de pas mal de
possibilités donc la cymbale est un
incontournable pour l'été encore cette
saison encore cette saison la sandale
est un incontournable parce que
finalement dès qu'il ya le moindre petit
rayon de soleil qu'on soit au mois de
mars et qui commence à faire un petit
peu beau on a tout de suite du moins les
femmes
et puis nous on voit tout de suite envie
de porter une sandale d'un qu'il ya ce
côté estivale il ya ce côté vraiment été
qui est associé à la sandale qui fait
que tout de suite des combats incertains
a l'impression qu'il fait tout de suite
beau donc il ya un aspect psychologique
de la sandale donc franchement c'est
même bon pour le moral à sandales
finalement
[Musique]
lorsqu'une femme prépare ses valises
pour les vacances la première chose
qu'elle mettra dans ses bagages est une
paire de sandales elle rime avec 20 de
soleil plage ou encore soirée qui se
prolonge en bord de mer la sandale cette
fameuse chaussure composé d'une semelle
et d'une ou plusieurs bride et multiples
spartiates tongs nu pieds ou encore
sandales à talons hauts il y en a pour
tous les styles
un dénominateur commun de large
ouverture pour évacuer la chaleur et
laisser nos orteils respirer même si
avec le recul historique
on réalise que la sandale ne fait pas
nécessairement partie des modèles de
prédilection de créateurs de haute
couture et des designers force est de
constater qu'en tant que chaussures à
hiré elle offre des possibilités de
création qui lui sont propres
ainsi l'accent est le plus souvent ni
sur la manière d'aborder la nudité du
pied ou en d'autres mots sur
l'interprétation tout à fait personnelle
qu'on l'a créateur de la notion de
légèreté si chez yves saint laurent et
nous adopte la forme de la bottine les
lanières entrecroisées selon une
structure de cages dévoilant le pied
confirmé leur statut de chaussures
ouvertes
nous sommes donc face à un modèle
alliant les codes de chaussures
différentes
la maison chanel quant à elle réinvente
des modèles classiques et intemporelles
dont l'extravagance réside surtout dans
les talons revolver associés et du satin
noir sobre ou encore en poule sur un
modèle de films paillettes noires qui
font toute l'originalité de la chaussure
à l'opposé alexander mcqueen connu pour
ses défilés extravagants et ses modèles
peu conventionnel parfois difficilement
abordable en dehors des tapis rouges
n'hésite pas encore une fois à
s'inspirer de toutes les grandes époques
artistique
a lyon la complexité du baroque et ses
dorures tapageuse à des lignes épurées
plus moderne et s'est tout récemment à
l'occasion de sa collection printemps
2012 que prada lance des modèles aux
formes alambiquées portant le nom de
rock trad dont les cuirs vernis de
couleur vive évoque les peintures
brillantes et les ailerons des voitures
américaines des années 50
le modèle mojito que vous voyez ici a
été créé par un certain julian sykes
issu d'une formation d'architecte plutôt
renversant n'est ce pas united nude une
marque hollandaise né de l'association
d'un architecte et d'un cordonnier
propose des chaussures pour le moins
anguleuse et structurée dans la série
impossible à porter scavo beautiful de
lindy von der weid heures diplômé en
design réinvente les bases mêmes de la
chaussure vers un renouveau des codes
esthétiques en voulant intégrer des
éléments de la technologie contemporaine
à la chaussure francesca castaner qui
recouvre de fibre optique ses chaussures
à tendance sobre sans doute ne vous
serait-il jamais venu à l'idée
contrairement à iris schäfer stein
d'utiliser des animaux morts comme base
d'inspiration pour vos souliers et
pourtant voici quelques sandales de sa
confection
parmi les sandales de chez kobi levi
designer reconnu pour ses modèles
originaux attendant celui dit est
inspiré du quotidien on retrouve par
exemple la chaussure lance pierre enfin
une sandale créée par alan nguyen et
jane kaikan and freedom of creation pour
frêche fiber inclut une coque pour
iphone de l'extérieur de sans talons ses
créateurs s'adresse ainsi tout
spécialement soit à des papes très
souple soit à toutes celles qui ont peur
de perdre leurs téléphones des cas ne
l'ont plus sous les yeux
[Musique]
mon petit conseils pour bien choisir sa
paire de sandales pour cet été bon alors
comme vous l'aurez remarqué je n'en
porte pas non car j'ai les collants
grave erreur mesdames vraiment même si
on en a vu partout dans paris ces temps
ci et même si on n'est toujours pas
d'accord avec moi je trouve que la
couture du collant avec le pied qui sort
c'est anti sexy et c'est une grave faute
de coûts donc pour cet été sans collants
partons sur quelque chose de très très
frais donc avec un corps pour le coup
qui est rose un peu un peu fuchsia bien
flashy avec un talent un petit peu
glossy donc avec de la fim paillettes
blanches
voilà une petite robe fluide ou même un
petit short ça passe vraiment très très
bien surtout si on est bronzée petite
manucure french manucure au bout des
pieds on est glossy et très très fraîche
alors on peut aussi évidemment les
mettre avec un petit short avec une
couleur un peu plus sombre voilà comme
c'est vrai que le corps est quand même
très flashy
n'oubliez surtout jamais que alliés
beaucoup de couleurs en haut et en bas
ça fait trop chargé du coup voilà tout
est suggéré tout est dans la chaussure
n'oubliez pas que la chaussure habille
le corps de la femme voilà et nous avons
aussi le choix avec une sandale à bout
fermé alors c'est un autre style et
c'est tout à fait sympa aussi
là on est parti sur quelque chose de
vraiment vraiment très glossy avec un
total look en finn paillettes blanches
et avec juste une petite sujet que
suggestions pardon de vernis vieux rose
ici donc à un modèle encore très glossy
et très près pour cet été mais dame là
je le vois vraiment plus avec une petite
robe très fluide
voilà on a quand même un côté paillettes
au pied donc rester simple avait quelque
chose de blanc ou même partent un peu
plus dans le fond c'est avait quelque
chose de marronner ou un petit peu un
petit peu kaki hyper sympa au pied pour
cet été
choisissez aussi mesdames par rapport à
la hauteur de talons des talents pas
trop car c'est quand même ouvert
derrière et c'est vrai que la stabilité
est moindre par rapport à un escarpin
fermé ce qui est normal donc là on est
sur un talon de
8 cm talons épais sur la sandale
précédente sur 1,8 cm talent enfin on
peut tenter de 10 cm bien évidemment
mais c'est vrai qu'on sera moins stable
donc voilà l'été le but c'est de ces
deux marchés long de la plage ou à
marcher dans les rues de paris et c'est
d'être vraiment stable et d'avoir un
vrai confort de marche donc allier le
côté pepsi et assez frais avec des
couleurs assez blanche assez fuchsia
rose etc
mais avec une hauteur de talon pas trop
haute voilà en alliant évidemment le
confort etc
mon conseil sur la sandale bien peu la
portée tout simplement avec un short
c'est très joli
ça fait toujours très chic sans pour
autant être en bord de mer ou en
vacances une sandale parfaite et pour
moi par définition déjà une sandale très
féminine est très confortable
les grandes tendances dans les matières
de sandales c'est que c'est une vague
qui ne termine pas donc le sandale
deviennent de plus en plus des corps est
il y a de plus en plus de filles kong
qui ont du mal à porter des talons très
haute
donc le sandale plat deviennent
incontournables donc je dirais le plus
grandes tendances qu'on voit dans le
scandale c'est cette notion de d'absence
progressive de talents très haute
alors pour porter une sandale en dans un
endroit urbaine il faut juste que le
fonds d'al un tout petit peu plus de
sophistication donc les tanks et les
birkenstock c'est peut-être mieux
2 les lacets port pour une vacance mais
dès qu'il y a des belles matières
ghesquière on a parlé des cuir métallisé
un des broderies des pères ce genre de
choses je trouve qu'ils ne peuvent être
très sophistiquée et il a toute sa place
à la fois dans une environnement
or ben comme dans une soirée quels sont
vos conseils nous pour la sandale
sandales voilà c'est une des paires que
je vois bien avec un avec un avec un
short
il y en a il n'y a pas beaucoup père que
joue avec des chats parce que souvent
ces attaques parfois un petit peu lâché
louette
donc je vois bien avec un short juste au
dessus du genou jeu bien sûr robes jeans
vraiment pu la mettre avec agrémenté
avec pas mal de choses attention pas de
faute de goût en associant à talons très
hauts et fin avec un évidement un jean
surtout à ne pas faire voilà chaussures
que franchement je que j'adore c'est
vraiment la sandale la sandale parce que
justement il ya cet effet deux brides à
la cheville qui enlace la cheville qui
donne vraiment ce côté ultra féminin et
puis à la fin on peut la porter avec un
avec un talon avec un talon un petit peu
plus bas c'est toujours toujours
toujours toujours très flatteur
pour les pour les jolies femmes qui la
portent et puis bon et c'est un modèle
tout de suite qui fait penser à des
choses joyeuses à l'été qui fait penser
à une tenue habillée ça peut être aussi
une tenue de soirée
donc moi vraiment c'est cette chaussure
là et que je privilégie j'adore vraiment
j'aime beaucoup ce style de chaussures
nakheel ce n'est pas toute l'année donc
récapitulons pour être au top de la
tendance avec vos sandales mesdames oser
les couleurs flashy et les matières
glossy mais pas trop non plus selon vos
vêtements
la french manucure pour montrer que vous
n'avez pas tout miser sur la chaussure
et comme conseil look le short vous ira
à ravir pour exposer vos jambes bronzées
al'inverse éviter les collants car la
couture qui dépasse de l'ouverture ce
n'est pas franchement sexy les talons
trop hauts pas très stable avec
seulement la bride pour maintenir le
talon et enfin à éviter coûte que coûte
si jamais vous prenez quand même le
risque des dalles en eau le jeans trop
différent dans la matière et l'état
d'esprit
la sandale et la chaussure estival par
excellence
légère et au minimalisme brut elle saura
se faire oublier et vous accompagner
aussi bien sur les pavés que sur la
plage elle existe sous différentes
formes spartiates tongs sandales à
talons à chaque femme sa sandale selon
votre style vous la choisir et plates ou
à talons pourvu qu'elles soient
suffisamment basique pour accompagner un
bon nombre de vos tenues
un bon conseil pour ne pas se tromper
les coloris kamel et noir sont des
valeurs sûres pour tous les jours si
vous cherchez un modèle féminin
la sandale se décline dans des versions
bijoux avec des strass ou encore des
perles de rocaille et naturellement pour
la plage une paire de tongs est
indispensable un conseil réfléchissez
bien avant de choisir une forme de
sondage original car le bronzage que
vous aurez en conséquence vous suivra
tout l'été à très bientôt pour la suite
d'histoires de souliers
[Musique]
oui